okay i'm coming from a household where i
did not see marriage growing up at all
so i have no like my parents were
divorced so like at all
so
anything that i saw in movies was what i
thought it was
so 50 of all marriages end in divorce is
santa now part of the statistic
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey everybody welcome to led live i hope
wherever you are you're staying warm and
you are having a wonderful holiday
season we're wishing you a a great time
together that you are spending this time
with us we thank you for that um it's
really been a neat year for us here at
little light studios um we have had a
blessed year so many things have just
gone
right for us this year that um it's kind
of neat to hear some stories like that
in the midst of of covid and all this
like calamity but um
you know we we got a a new building this
year we raised funds for the building
and praise god you guys have donated
amazingly to us and we were able to
actually take care of the whole building
we're still doing a little bit of a
donation appeal for um actually
outfitting out the studio but i got a
lot of thanks and a lot of praises this
year how about you guys
yeah
so when you think of the holiday season
what do you think of
family
traveling traveling
traveling where though
just traveling forever okay to see
family there you go i think of gifts yes
or i guess materialism because this is
like the best sales coming around this
time
you know it's funny like uh speaking of
that uh you know everybody tries to get
the gifts before and everything's price
height way high right and you know after
christmas everything falls i have
actually heard of people saying you know
what i will give you money to the kids
i'll give you money to spend on
christmas it'll be x but if you wait
till after christmas i'll double that
and i'll tell you what all those kids
all the time would always say well wait
till afterwards
that's good economics too i think that's
a good lesson isn't it yeah delayed
gratification you know so what do you
think of when you think of the holiday
season i think of grace grace that's a
good one yeah i have a um advent wreath
on my table and every day you put out a
candle and it has a little baby jesus
well it's actually mary on a donkey and
it goes around the wreath until it gets
to the center and one year i used small
candles and it burnt the mule's face
when it got
close to the center so if you have one
don't do that but um but i think that
there's so much that can distract you in
this season that the very reason for it
is just lost so it's like you kind of
have to be really intentional about
saying this is what we're celebrating
you know it's the grace of the
savior and really it's about
relationships right
i mean you guys all mentioned that over
christmas time or over the holiday
season it's really about getting
together with your family right and you
mentioned
birth i mean that's really god coming
down and spending time
in amongst us
walking in amongst us that's a
relationship right
and so um i think the holiday season is
definitely centering around that people
are are are generally looking forward to
the holiday season with warm feelings i
know some people have um very uh not
warm feelings for for whatever you know
if there's a tragedy that happened or
you know something that that
maybe would make this time of the year a
little bit more difficult so there are
people that are not always looking
forward or anticipating this time of the
year um
but generally speaking i think most
people look forward to it with warm
feelings when you agree yes yes
okay so
i want to play a commercial for you that
i saw
we have yet to see this by the way yeah
nobody nobody in here has actually seen
this commercial um really nervous and i
really want to know your thoughts about
this commercial because um it was pretty
interesting it's not from this country i
want to mention that um but it was about
this warm fuzzy time of the year that we
all
seem to
enjoy and look forward to here's the
commercial
it's a little crazy
by the way has anyone seen this
commercial no okay awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
i think it's interesting
that they're in a church
[Music]
this is a commercial this is a
commercial it's a whole show
dude that's creepy
[Music]
oh
what's going on
it's a commercial isn't this crazy
[Music]
okay
so what he said right there was
i employed somebody else so i could have
the time off
and i can now spend it with you
[Music]
sorry i'm sorry
wow
like
what
where did this come from
what country is this
i don't wait till afterwards
so their attention span must be amazing
if their commercials are like a minute
and 30 seconds long also what are they
advertising okay hold on
so what this says right here is that
they have 50 years
of being able to choose whom they want
to love
oh
oh god what
good you
it's basically saying like happy
holidays but we've had 50 years
to be able to choose whom we want to
love okay
so what is this what what do you think
it looks like a postal service or
something
i think and this is like totally
deviating from the obvious
but the thing that kind of strikes me is
that's the message of the gospel is god
with us and i know you know there's the
overt homosexuality that's portrayed but
to me
the fact that he was wanting the
presence of santa
not the gifts and the trimmings but the
presence and relationship to me i was
just like wow i mean that was really
powerful of course you didn't
i was kind of suspecting where that was
going but i think that accidentally is
kind of the message of the gospel
embedded in it
okay so
you're bringing up a good point it's a
postal service by the way that's what
they were they were promoting so it's
like it's like the united states postal
office this is norway's postal service
doing a commercial so this is a
government
commercial saying that for 50 years
50 years
they have the freedom to love whom they
want okay great message wouldn't you say
you love who you want right is that a
good message
yeah yes it is
wait so let me ask you so let me ask you
something but let me ask you a question
half of what he said
if i want to love whomever i want
what if that love all of a sudden
happens to a 12 year old
oh wait a minute but now there's a line
do you see what i'm saying
the there's an interesting thing that's
happening here they were putting this
idea out during christmas when everybody
has these warm and fuzzy feelings right
and this is not a discussion on
homosexuality i'm just i'm just pointing
this out that it's very interesting
because there's a lot of dynamics here
that a lot of people aren't thinking
about when you're watching this
where is mrs santa
it doesn't exist dang i didn't even
think about her i mean what about mrs
santa isn't santa claus actually married
yeah mrs claus
we don't see her a lot in all fairness
and a lot of things he gets a lot more
attention than she does
how many like at least in this country
how many holiday
you know like at the mall or something
like how many people i have a set of
grandparents who used to do that um my
grandma is she's she's passed away
in the last couple years
but she was married to a man who both of
them together they just had the look
they almost got a gig at disney
they had it down and they would have
little kids come to them if they were
out in public and the kids would come up
and start like spilling like what they
wanted
for christmas
to them just just because they they
looked the look wow well they say
everyone has a doppelganger so
cnn has a few you know from that
perspective i'm looking at it like you
know that was a package deal you know
it's like yeah maybe she's not the most
prominent figure
but it's still a part of the equation
50 years seems like a really long time i
think even in this country it's right
about 10 if that that homosexual
marriage has been legalized
norway is a secular
a heavily secular place right so i i
find it interesting um
that they had throughout the whole thing
it was a
like a religious song and there was
scenes within a church so it's kind of
that dual thing where they're glorifying
uh the freedom to love and how
progressive they are and more like
secular but at the same time they have
this religious element
it's like i'm wondering who their um
audience is
is it kind of are they trying to um
cater to many different people by having
all these different elements in there
yeah that's a good point
it's kind of an interesting thing
because
you saw in here there was the
relationship aspect he's home with his
family he's home with his is you know
loved ones and he's longing to to have
this love that he sees coming and stuff
like that so it is playing upon an
emotion that i think god is instilled in
every single one of us that's the desire
to love and be loved oh you asked about
mrs claus we didn't see his or the
mother of his child either did you guys
catch that i didn't see a child is that
or
that yeah either that or he was the
young caller who you know all right
i think he was just there with his
family but it's it's kind of an
interesting um interesting thing that
they're playing on and i think that um
you know
this is not a discussion on
homosexuality this is not a discussion
on um on even that i'm just i'm just
throwing the question out there like
really honestly
there is a lot of kids who believe santa
is real when they're little and they
know that santa is married so playing
this out there is i think really going
to reinterpret
that with children i think it's children
that are going to be more impacted by
seeing something santa claus than an
adult does that make sense and i think
that's the point it's about diversity
and equality yes i mean have you guys
seen african african-american santa i've
seen one that's not the norm you know so
all these different types of santas out
there i can hear the argument that's
saying oh that won't distort the the
view of a child who's heterosexual it's
more for the homosexual child that we're
doing this for or whatever the case yeah
but i think once again the the argument
stands that the more that we see it in
public the more that we see it in our
setting the more that it becomes
acceptable and normalized
so i this really um kind of got me
thinking about relationships because the
devil's number one attack is against a
relationship right
and so
during the holidays um it's it's it's
interesting because we have these
relationships and and and so i started
looking at like divorce rates just
around the world because i just wanted
to see this um you know did santa get a
divorce like what's up
he's all of a sudden single like you
know that that information was not told
to us but i i was curious about this and
um so i found out some really
interesting stuff where do you think is
the least divorces in our country
somewhere in the midwest
you would say the midwest what would you
say
maybe alaska because there's fewer
people there
okay i found this to be pretty shocking
okay you're you're you're almost wrong
in that area wow
so don't choose your answer yeah
um
i don't know
am i allowed to say that okay so if you
look at this graph right here
9.5 is least it's a hawaii 14 is
greatest so you can match the colors
where's the where's the yeah where's the
least awesome where the sunshine is oh
interesting california and new york
isn't that fascinating to me hawaii yeah
utah yeah some of the most progressive i
would say liberal state has the least
but they might have the least amount of
marriages right they might just be
partners without americans okay okay
that's a good point that's a good point
yeah so is the most
the most maine oh i mean in nevada and
nevada probably
exactly
i mean does anyone know
the population of maine
i don't know i don't know
so i want to read to you um a couple of
of statistics on marriage and stuff
i found it kind of interesting marriage
and divorce both common experiences for
adults um about 90 percent of people in
western cultures get married by the age
of 50. did you know that 90 that's a lot
right in the united states about 50
percent of married couples divorce
50 mercy okay so one out of every two is
not gonna make it we are the sixth
highest divorce rate in the world
in the united states i found that kind
of interesting
sixth highest subsequent marriage has
even higher divorce rates 60 of second
marriages end up in divorce and 73
percent of third marriages end up in
divorce
and these are these are some kind of
alarming statistics but did you know
that um there is actually um the divorce
rate is going down
there's actually getting less divorces
per capita of people than
back in the 1990s did you know that is
that in relation to the two
amount of marriages though people may be
getting
married less and they might be living
with heart could be a fact at least what
i've heard is that
people are waiting longer because you
have
so that the generation that had high
divorce rates or maybe where it was at
its peak those kids
of those people took a step back and
said
obviously this isn't working very well
and so a lot of them are delaying
their before they get married so they're
waiting more they're getting more
established in their career and their
lives and their friendship circles and
really taking time to figure out what
they want yeah
and so you're
not seeing the divorce rates as
high at least not yet i mean that could
always change over time but
the divorce rate average divorce age i
should say is 30 years old couples are
more likely to get divorced based on
several factors
couples married between the ages of 20
to 25 or 60 more likely to get a divorce
if you're able to make it older than 25
that decreases to 24
and
those with strong religious beliefs only
14 percent less likely to get a divorce
wow
you know what i i heard um a statistic
recently that talked about the divorce
rate amongst religious people and they
said that those couples that actually
prayed together
stayed together and that had a much
higher percentage and i thought that was
kind of an interesting statistic
according to the u.s census of bureau's
survey the top three reasons for divorce
are
incompatibility infidelity and money
issues oh i thought money would be at
the top but okay yeah that's changed
yeah accordingly to the u.s census
bureau survey so i don't know unless
people are not like telling the truth
about their money but those are the
those are the things that this census
found um to be the top of three reasons
incompatibility and isn't it sad that
god made us all diverse and what a
beautiful thing that we get to be
diverse
and yet that's the one thing that just
kind of rips us at the seams it's
interesting you know at my age everyone
every adult i come across is asking that
question you know what's happening with
you and your love life but i've heard
like two
opposite views when it comes to the age
to get married get married young and
they have their reasons and then get
married older because
um it's not until like 27 and up that
you really solidify who you are so if
you get married too young you might in a
few years get to know who this person
really is and then that incompatibility
aspect comes up and it is more fragile
than just waiting to figure it out and
then um seeing who the person is you
guys think i suppose if you're judging
it by the straight statistics
that waiting seems to have a better
result down the road
that's just judging from the that right
my suggestion is that god knows exactly
who you need to be with this is true and
so i don't know if that factored into
this census at all
but i would say that if you're coming to
god saying lord i give it to you i'm in
a relationship with you and i'm gonna
allow you to choose that other person i
think your chances are going to be much
greater i know that is my my case i
would be divorced for sure
with all the relationships that i had
prior to my wife it wasn't until i
actually said i don't want a girl
anymore i just want you lord and then
all of a sudden he introduced me to my
wife so that's that's my suggestion to
you
all right so divorce rate in america
another interesting statistics um that i
came across
that was kind of fascinating and the
reason why i'm talking about this in the
first place listen to some of these
highlights they found out the current
divorce rate is 2.9 persons in every 1
000. now it used to be 6 in every 1 000.
so to me that's kind of good news right
that we're kind of sticking around but i
think it's for some of those reasons
that you brought up maybe perhaps um we
are are
being more cautious with just not
jumping into into a relationship
um
right right there divorces amongst
people age 50 plus is rising so anyone
over 50 years old it's doubling
like anyway go ahead why would you think
that
i mean don't you find it interesting
that here um in in santa and uh you know
this other gentleman that they're two
older older people
finding this relationship you know
there's a lot of relationships where
people get beyond the 50 years old and
they're just like you know what i don't
want to do this anymore well i mean
you have the empty nest syndrome i guess
and then also
isn't this around the time midlife
crisis
[Laughter]
could be you know but i know like
um well i've heard a lot of times like
when you bring kids into the mix you
don't really
a lot of couples kind of fall apart
within that time because they don't get
to know each other anymore they don't
they stop going on dates and all that
and so
if you guys don't
communicate together within that time
and get to know each other and have days
where you don't talk about the kids or
anything like that then i can see why it
would fall apart you know the kids leave
you're like who who are you like how did
you change the last 15 years the wisdom
coming from somebody that's not even in
the in a marriage relationship you have
to spend time in your relationships
right you have to work on those
relationships there it's like it's like
anything else a plant if you stop
watering the plant or taking care of the
plant that plant's going to die that
same thing is going to happen to your
marriage you have to put the time in
to to
continue to grow with each other learn
with each other fall in love with each
other it's a daily experience
wouldn't you say
i heard something really interesting
about your uh your marriage uh oh you
tell
i can't wait i don't know if you want to
tell but uh mikey was sharing with us a
little bit before and just that uh you
what you were able to wait for your
husband and that's just a beautiful
thing you don't hear about that right
okay about virginity it's it's totally
safe to say that okay you're not going
to be awkward
um yes and and to be honest that was
like my biggest fear i thought i'm going
to die a virgin at 19. i mean i was more
afraid of that probably than going to
hell
that just seemed like you know the end
of the world to me um
but i did a part of it was probably if
i'm honest probably fear because i had
been raised in a very very harsh
religious environment where that was
just like the unpardonable sin but i
think part of it was
even from the age of 12 and on i saw the
vulnerability of that and i saw the way
guys talked about girls in the locker
room and how degraded something that's
so intimate and so personal it was just
like sport i thought wow do you want to
make yourself horrible to someone that's
going to talk about a sports court you
know
and so that just really um
you know made me back up quick from that
but um
i do think though that part of it is
i don't think we really understand the
sexual aspect of covenant i've seen this
diagram and it's really interesting
depicting
the temple of solomon versus the human
body
and it was designed like the human body
and i think there's something that you
know scripture calls us the temple of
the holy spirit i think there's
something that we don't really grasp
that is so weighty and i think that's
why there's such an attack on sexuality
because there's something about it that
is so intimate and covenant-making that
when you distort that and you water it
down and you disperse it it weakens
covenant and it weakens the spiritual
aspect and the devil knows that more
than we do we're kind of dumb and like
hey you know it was really fun at the
time and we don't understand what was
you know the ramification of that and
what god was really portraying through
that there are so many life lessons in
our physical world for us to understand
these deep spiritual things um it is
very interesting that in the jewish
sanctuary system
the only one that was allowed into the
most holy place was the high priest
in your marriage situation you as
men as the high priest should be the
only ones allowed into certain spaces
with that yeah there's there's there's a
lot of cross over there that we can
understand the deep spiritual things of
god just looking at our physical
relationships and i think that's why the
devil hates our physical relationship so
bad he wants to break us up make you
just go off in every which direction and
chase your feelings and everything and
and um you know not really um
you know understand our relationships
are more than just do i feel like like
like i'm in love with this person you
know it's much more of a of an
intellectual thing as well
i think our relationship with god is the
same
so listen to this um the u.s divorce
rate um is amongst one of the highest in
the world there are about 750 000
divorces in the u.s each year
most americans who file for divorce do
so between what months
january and march now why do you think
that is
yeah i mean all of that is really
fascinating to me that that's something
i didn't even think about there's a time
whether money regulates and like trying
to figure out your finances after
blowing a bunch
of years
exactly that's right after the holidays
getting hold and everybody's stuck
inside together
everybody gets together and looks
forward for this holiday i'm gonna be
with my friends and family and this and
that and then the first thing they do in
the next year hit the ground running
with like yeah i don't want this person
anymore i find that kind of interesting
and fascinating that's why this kind of
commercial when i first saw it just
really struck me and it was like a stark
thing of like whoa whoa there's there's
a lot of detail here that that wasn't
talked about and i think like you get
wrapped up in the emotion of what
they're showing you instead of thinking
through like you know hey they're
actually portraying something that that
that i don't believe is it is a good
thing
getting you know into the
without getting into a big discussion
about christmas and stuff like that i
mean just i've always thought santa was
married to mrs santa
i i have a question
what do you think about um because
obviously in america we can choose who
we want to marry but there are countries
like india some middle eastern cultures
that
they get into arranged marriages how do
you think
um
that they would look at us because we
look at them and say oh man you can't
choose who you want to marry but they
likely end up staying married
i know there are other
like there's cultural things why you
shouldn't get divorced either but then
like you have us
where we can choose and we can't even
stay married
so i i really honestly believe that if
if
i've gone through all of these life
experiences and all of a sudden my son
is getting to the age where he is
looking for a girl and i have feel like
i have had quite a few experiences to
where i could say yeah yeah don't pick
that one don't yeah yeah you do this i
feel like my vantage point is at a
different point than his he hasn't had
the life experience and all that kind of
stuff right and so i could see how that
would be a good thing if the parent is
really looking for the for the child's
well-being right and so um in the old
ancient days that should have been what
was really making those marriages
successful unfortunately um you know the
human heart is wicked right deceitful
and so i'm sure a lot of times that gets
exploited people want this person to
marry your son because it you makes a
union of these two families and you know
what i mean so there's probably all
sorts of exterior things that would make
that a difficult situation right
but um
here's some other details from this the
average length of the marriage in the
u.s is 8.2 years
wow
that's not a lot that's very sobering
it's not a lot of years
praise god i've gone past that i'm
celebrating 14 this next year i will be
20. wow 25 years not even that old i
know i know i've been married longer
than i've been alive yeah how's that
happen that's awesome a quarter of a
century that's crazy praise god
did you know that co-habiting
can impact your risk of divorce
absolutely
absolutely absolutely because i believe
that you have this open door you're not
married and so if there's something i
don't like about you then
i can get out of this easily that's
my take on that it is and that's that's
one of the factors that they've studied
that you're more inclined to move in
with somebody that you wouldn't marry
than to marry somebody that you wouldn't
marry you know because it is easier it's
just pack your stuff and move out
there's no attorneys and no you know
yeah it's too easy i've seen a ted talk
about a lady who was talking about
relationships
and she was even saying how facebook or
other social media platforms can become
a little bit of a a little black book
you know it's like a back door they keep
some relationships alive because well
what if this doesn't work out you know i
need to have somebody in my back corner
you know that i can
communicate with and start to part my
heart out to or you know meet up with
someday if it just doesn't work but if
you go into a relationship with that
thought like
may not you know it's probably not going
to work or it may not work so i better
prepare for exit strategy
it's like preparing for failure yep yeah
i think that
marriage is difficult enough and so you
know if you leave you know any option on
the table
chances are times are going to get rough
every marriage has a rough time have you
had a rough time absolutely you had a
rough time i've had a rough time you
guys going to have a rough time probably
but was it all worth it yes was it all
worth it
it was all worth it so i'm just throwing
that out there to you guys i don't want
to scare you okay we had a couple
tell us a long time ago
um
i remember them saying you know
you're going to get to about 10 years
and it's going to start to get hard
it took up to 10 years
three months wow i was like
okay
[Laughter]
i didn't think much of that at the time
but i but i remembered it
and it turned out to be true
for us
about the 10-year mark you know
somewhere in that eight to ten year
range it did get hard we had
four kids
one of them was a two-year-old
there was very little time you know to
spend together all the energy and
focuses on the kids
and it was at that point where i
remember
you know those those whisperings come
into your mind
and you start thinking about it i
started thinking i was like man like
what if it's gonna keep going like this
like are we destined for divorce you
know and
wow i pushed those thoughts out of my
head because i knew they weren't from
god
but
they certainly
you know they certainly came around a
certain those those feelings of doubt
started coming and i couldn't imagine
being with anybody else
or or going through that process or
watching my kids go through that kind of
pain
but
the whisperings were there you know it
was a hard hard time now after that it
got better
but
um
but it was rough for a little bit i
think i'll go ahead but you just had
doubt right it wasn't like you woke up
one morning and said i don't like her
anymore i don't even think she's pretty
you know it wasn't it wasn't anything
like that it was just like
you
don't have time for each other
it was just like everything was was all
about the kids
and
you know even now we talk about that
we're both excited because we've been
married for
16 going on 17 years now
and
you know we're excited because we're
going to go back and visit family
missouri and we're going to go on a date
we haven't been on like a real date in
like two years
it's hard you get four kids in the mix
it's like who's going to watch four kids
for
a sufficient amount of time for you to
go and
do something it's rough you know
maybe you can farm them out to different
families and stuff and it's not like one
two kids or it's it's a little bit
easier we don't have grandparents in the
area
we don't have other family in the area
we have friends
um
we try not
to as we put it you know burden them
with four children two of which are
teenagers and can eat a lot right um but
yeah it's it's
it has its moments where it's
challenging but yeah we never had that
experience where it's like i don't love
you anymore we don't we don't care about
each other it's it's not that
but
it's definitely something that's on my
mind a lot it's like i love that lady
you know yeah and i want to pay
attention to her i want to make her life
easier and great and
but there's there's also a principle
because
you know as we as we talk about this
i'm sitting here wondering like well why
do a lot of people want to get married
what are they expecting
when they get married
there are preconceived notions that we
have
right we go into a marriage and we think
it's going to be like this
is that because of the movies
probably you know it's it's like it's
all lies warm fuzzies all the time you
know
you know your your intimacy is gonna be
like this or that and you just have all
these
ideas like this is this is how it's
gonna be
well
what if all of that
wasn't like you thought it was
or isn't like you think
you know what are you expecting to get
out of the marriage
are you expecting anything
maybe
i'm not saying you shouldn't expect to
get or you shouldn't have any
expectations but marriage is not all
about me
it's about the other person that's right
and so if i go into the marriage
thinking
what am i going to get out of this
then it's going to mess up you know that
that beautiful experience
and there's a
there's a saying that i heard that says
love
is a principle
in other words it's not it's not these
it's not the warm fuzzies
it's not this feeling that you get
it's not the
it's not
the it's not lust it's not the intimacy
part of it some of those things are part
of the whole experience but love is a
principle that means i love you
because
of who you are because god loved me i
love and i'm going to continue loving
you even if things are hard
even if
um you know we have a rough year
even if you know you wake up with a
wrinkle or what have you it's love is a
principle it keeps on loving look at us
the bible says that god loved us while
we were yet sinners that's a principle
that's not
it's not it's god looking at like man
you guys are so great i just love you
you did so much for me and you're so
beautiful no we're the ugliest thing in
the universe
all right after satan and his angels i
suppose that's why i think the bible
talks about loving your wives as christ
loved the church you know it's like
the church has not a good history of
being good to god
in fact they've had a terrible track
record and they've constantly cheated on
him and run away but christ was was
willing to
see it through
and die for them so that they would have
something so it was this other focused
thing and i think our marriages are are
equally the same keith i heard about
what you were saying as well and i heard
it put that love is a choice that you
make not a feeling that you have
so it doesn't matter the circumstance if
you decide that this is the person that
i'm committing myself to it's a choice
that you have to get up every morning
and make
and i think a real practical thing too
is well um there's going to be things
that bother you in a marriage right
always there's little things that just
irk you and if you focus on those little
things those little things will begin to
grow into a mountain right
rather than do you know it's interesting
that if you actually focus on the things
that you like about that person or that
you really enjoy that they do
those things grow into an appreciation
in the same way that that other thing
would grow into a mountain your love
grows because you're sitting there
focusing on wow
this person is so unique and beautiful
and does these amazing things and if
they let that be the the focal point
rather than tearing them down with what
they're not doing or what they're not
being or whatever um those those kind of
things that will will just destroy your
marriage from the inside out
so i have a question
i guess we're the three married people
in the room
so why should someone get married if
it's so difficult
because it teaches you how to love
someone else
i think that's the one thing that
marriage is impacted me the most
um is it it showed me that my world
wasn't all just about me
oh wow there's this other person that my
choices affect this other person and
it's like this intimate relationship
that no matter what i do
impacts that person
and so it just really teaches you to to
intimately have this appreciation and
affection for others
that's what it's done for me like with
puppies
or adopted child like let's say i'm a
single mother
of an adopted child and children once
again bring another layer of complexity
to that or understanding about that yeah
is here you now have these selfish
little beans that come into your world
that all of a sudden it's all about them
feed me please me
change my diapers do all this work for
me and you're
exhausted running around thinking like
are you kidding me if i would have known
what i was getting into i would have
never had kids in the first place
but they're worth every ounce of energy
you put into them and i think the
marriage is the same
i would say though that i love being
married and i love the
best friend partner aspect of it i think
that
just having somebody to share a movie
with or a conversation with or tell
about your day or when you're going
through something having somebody that
has known you for 25 years knows how for
example a few years ago you know i'm an
empty nester
and i told my husband i said you know
i'm revisiting the idea of going back
and getting my degree in law because
that's back in the day i was going to be
the district attorney
and um
he said deborah i think that you would
do so well with the litigation part he
said but you know goodwill most of law
is a lot of tedious dreadful sitting at
a desk and stuff he said that's not you
and he knows me so i was like oh you're
right you're right so
but i think that there's something
that's so precious and i think that some
of what makes marriage dreadful is we
don't really understand what it was for
and i will just freely say we usually
come to marriage and to god well not
usually we do for selfish reasons there
might be a few
very
uh unique souls who said i want to lay
down my life be trampled on give away
all my money go go to work stay up late
do all this stuff and just take care of
another human being i am not that person
i think most people come because we do
have these notions of what this is going
to
bring to me you know and uh and then we
come to god for the same reason you know
we weren't just sitting on our launcher
thinking i bet god needs a friend today
i think i'm just gonna hang out with him
we're probably destitute and i've done
everything there is to do and it didn't
work okay maybe this is our last you
know card to play and um so i think that
you learn and grow and you make a lot of
mistakes and you do a lot of wrong stuff
and
you misunderstand the meaning of
marriage and you're selfish with then
you take it for granted in the mids of
that god's grace starts teaching you
this is a portrayal of christ in the
church that's why we don't understand it
in a natural it's kind of it doesn't
make sense i mean animals do not pair up
and stay together usually for their
lifetime they can have babies and
everybody can survive and they don't
need to have a house and bills and all
that
but there's something unique about
humanity that we are a portrayal in the
world of
if i'm around scotty and i see him just
being super precious to his wife and
just loving her and care about her i
don't know i might not know anything
about the gospel i'm like wow he is just
so unconditionally loving or i don't
know if he's like that or not but i'm
just saying he's smiling like of course
of course she's been watching me but
anyway
but it speaks something to people
because it's not natural where it's
natural for us to be selfish and do
everything for us and demand everything
for us so when we see that we're like
wow what's making that guy do that
what's he getting out of so i think that
um
that part of divorce comes from we don't
understand what marriage is we come into
it seeking we really come into it
seeking salvation if we're honest we
think marriage is this redeeming saving
come in on the white horse and swoop me
up and take me away to my castle and
it's it's totally not that
um and so i think that because we have
this wrong expectation from the outset
like keith was talking about why are you
getting married if we don't understand
that it's a covenant you look at um
david and
the friend jonathan you look at david
john and they obviously weren't a
married couple
but they had this very unique and very
close relationship and they cut covenant
with each other and it was to the death
like i'm going to be with you take care
of you and shelter you if you know the
story of marcus luttrell
the
sole survivor
he was one of the navy seals that his
whole team was shot and he was he was
taken in in the middle east by this
group of people and i have a word and i
don't know it unfortunately but it's
this word that basically means almost
something like covenant and these people
took him in and they protected him with
their own lives until the american
people could be there
and so he um
but some of the other cultures
understand covenant more than we do
we're not we're you know not from that
when jesus came to walk the earth and
when he established marriage and all
that they understood that we don't we
look at it contractually as long as you
please me here's the terms of our
agreement when you quit pleasing me i
trade you in trade my 40 in for 220 is
right around 50.
you know and so i think that we
we don't even understand what we're
getting into
and that's part of the problem and i
think that as believers
i'm gonna wrap up my long time right
here but as believers and one thing that
i'm still learning after all the years
i've been married is
if we are not full of christ when we get
married and we come seeking and saving
that person we're going to constantly be
disenchanted
we're never going to quit needing that
source i don't care how great your
spouse is to you we were designed to
have a source from christ alone and when
we misplace that and idolize another
human being and say you're my jesus
you're going to meet all my needs we
automatically put the marriage in peril
we automatically put them in position
they can never fulfill and so as long as
you start off with the outset that god
is my source and out of that i'm giving
out and i'm still learning that
um
then i think that you have a much better
survival rate of your marriage because
you understand why it is and isn't it's
not there to fulfill you it's not there
to meet all your needs and it's not your
source
you bring up a really interesting point
when god created
adam
he could have easily made adam and eve
at the same time and he did he was just
in his body she was in his body yes but
he created adam and hung out with that
right
and it's like he built this relationship
with adam
and then
said i'm going to present to you your
mate
and i think that's that's a lesson for
us like um i think that we need to make
that relationship with christ
first and foremost and realize that
that's that's that's our our true real
relationship i mean obviously um you
know it's a it's a
union together so it's not just jesus
doesn't matter what you do i'm just you
know focused on him but um i think
that's an interesting point that you
brought up you were
you while you were talking about um how
someone viewing a couple together can be
like their little glimpse of the gospel
remind me of this quote and maybe you
can help me out keith um if i remember
it correctly it's like um
people
or marriage and the family is a glimpse
of heaven on earth is that correct
um and when you think about it what it
takes to get to heaven you have to have
that relationship with jesus christ he
needs to be at the center and then
having the fruits of the spirit and all
these things if that's also applied in
the marriage how it can be a success
i guess to answer your question i'd say
this
before you get married or before i got
married i see myself a certain way
after i got married
i understood more
what i was really like
and
through that process
i see
what god wants me to become
so
through you know through my wife i see
where i fall short in so many ways
and
how
you know what what god wants to draw out
in me and and make me
she's been a person that i've that i've
observed over these you know last
almost 20 years we've known each other
and seen how
giving and loving and selfless she is
and i've looked at that and like wow
like i am not like that you know
and i see that example and say yeah
that's what god is calling me to do he's
calling me to be
more
selfless
so that's that's a major lesson i've
learned through her and i think with
with all of us it's there's probably
similar things you know we see ourselves
a certain way and then we see
what
what it is that we're actually not you
know we think we're all that or we think
we're something and then god shows us
what we're really like
and then he shows us now this is what i
want you to become
so you go into it expecting to be a
better person
yeah or to have your spouse tell you
what
is wrong with you
all right don't tell my wife it just it
just seems like
i don't know you know it's crazy like
it's it's genuine fear is what it is
when you just the thought of
i have my heart and entrusting it to
someone else and they
can literally do whatever whether it's
love my heart or shatter it to a million
pieces right but then i thought yes if
it is vulnerable
that's exactly what i'm experiencing and
enjoying with jesus christ that's right
like he has given me his heart he gave
me his life that's right and it's
completely my choice and
you know he he's being vulnerable with
me and he's asking me to do the same
with someone else so i can experience
just a little bit of what he's
experiencing with me and many people
trample on it and so he has that risk as
well if i'm gonna get hurt or i can get
hurt if i give myself fully to this
person like this and that's also what
happens in a marriage
so how do you end
how do you individualize that because
let's say like that's something that
i've always struggled with is
my relationship with jesus being
um
i guess i can say personal because let's
say i decide you know what jesus i don't
want your heart thanks for dying on
across me but whatever i'm done i don't
really want this he still has like two
billion other people
that exercise you know what i'm saying
but then like if i were to get married
and that person was like
nah i don't like you anymore then it's
like wow like that was the one person
who had my heart
who broke it
you know i don't have like a bunch of
other people
you know like i think that's the same
still applies because um god's got you
you know he's got your back and
you know he just as you're saying he has
all these other people he can provide
if it's his will that other person to
maybe take that place of the person who
walked away here's what i would say to
that
i have four children
[Laughter]
if one of them was like you know what
i'm done with you and i'm gonna go do my
own thing you know it's nice that you
know you you and mom got together and
and created me but you know what i'm
just done and i'm gonna go do my own
thing and now
yeah
that would
crush me
now i still have three other children
who love me and care about me that's
pretty good odds you know seventy-five
percent
but the one that
the one that came to me and said that
yeah
it there would be a hole in my heart
until they came back
with the prodigal son waiting there but
i would speak to that because that's
actually where i am right now and god
has got me meditating
um
it's romans i want to think 9 at the end
of chapter 8 or chapter 9 where it talks
about where paul said i'm persuaded
that nothing can separate me from the
love of god because whether you're never
married or you're in a dating
relationship or even married for years
the potential for that person to just
gut you destroy you leave you say you're
not good enough if you're not free
enough this other person is better
that that vulnerability is always there
you know um and i think that
with vulnerability and with that
potential fear can come into that place
and then when fear comes in you can
start to control and you can start to
obsess and you can become dysfunctional
these ways because you're trying hard to
prevent that pain you're trying to
prevent that loss that now that i've
experienced this and if this was taken
away i would just be devastated you know
wipe that on the street
and so even being married as long as i
have
that is still a struggle in my life and
the last couple days god has just been
like i want you just meditating this day
and night nothing can separate you from
the love of god because the truth is
there is that potential every one of us
has been married for years our spouse
could walk in and say hey i found this
other person hey you know you're not and
as far as what um peter said he may have
never woken up and been like i don't
like you anymore we have there are days
we do not like each other why don't you
just go out and golf for a few hours or
whatever it is
but that's the grace of covenant it's
not based on our foolishness and our
emotions god help us if it was there's a
third party it says a three-fold court
is not easily broken a two-fold court be
broken in two minutes as soon as you
quit pleasing me but the covenant god
says even when you're acting crazy i've
still got you you're in the ark you're
not out in the waves you're in the ark
and noah no matter what he did if he
fell down he fell down in the ark he
didn't fall out of it you know it might
have been some animal poo around and
when he fell back
he was protected he was safe because he
had entrusted himself in that arc and i
think that part of it is
we don't understand what god will
provide in our marriage there is
protection on our marriages there is
there is a verse that says
if you as a believer defraud another
believer by you know taking their spouse
god will avenge that i don't know what
that verse means and i've never had
anybody else know and interpret it but
it blatantly says god will avenge that
there's something about covenant when he
wrote covenant with abraham and
different people in the bible it was to
the death you don't mess with covenant
and when we
trifle with that we don't really
understand it but when we enter in and
say i'm treating this marriage's
covenant god will say i'm going to war
for you it's not about you somebody
touches covenant i'm going to be there
because it was conan it's his idea it's
not ours right we can't protect we can't
defend it but all that to say
um
the the deeper security is that there's
something deeper that holds you if that
happened to you that your heart is not
just for naught and you didn't matter
and you're thrown away and that person
can destroy you and move on and you're
just in ashes you know the the fact is
paul never got married as far as we know
and he went through all this crazy stuff
but he had a source that wasn't human
that he could say
i don't know if the married people said
that you know
um he said i'm persuaded that nothing
can separate me from the law of god for
me i'd rather have that if i had to
choose i'd rather have that deep or
greater nothing can separate me from
love god than a temporary fleeing
because eventually one of your spouse is
just going to die even if they loved you
until they died you know and so i think
that that takes away that fear
of i've already got what i need i'm just
asking god to give me somebody to share
it with me it says that we as spouses
are heirs together of the grace of life
we're not supposed to be a life support
for each other we're supposed to be
sharing something together that we each
have equally
so if one of us is gone you still have
your portion of it
yeah there's a bible verse that says
that there is no fear and love and that
perfect love casts out fear first jones
foreign good girl all right
so i i want to wrap this up with um
just kind of a little bit of inspiration
like you guys have been listening to us
talk about well you guys have been
talking to we hearing us talk about some
of the triumphs and the struggles in
marriage and things like this but there
there is a i think a direct link with
with if we're having bad teachers of
marriages
that's got to have an impact upon our
life right that's right so you know me
i'm always like okay what's the media
teach in our society right so i just
looked up something the
20 top most grossing
uh romance movies of all time we're
going to go on
we're going to go through this list a
little bit let's see if i watch them
okay let's see
let's see
because you may have a fear of marriage
that is unnaturally placed inside of you
i'm just one i'm just throwing that out
there okay so what do you think is on
this list just just give me the notebook
okay or of the roast i'm just kidding
have you some of y'all seen that it's a
horrible movie
okay so i guess we won't uh call you
guys out and see which movie you have
seen number 20 on the list was what
women want nope i've probably seen that
a long time ago
and then he basically exploits the
woman's because he could hear her what
she's saying to try and win her um 19
500 19th highest grossing romance
i never could bring myself to watch it
can i point out something here
okay
just observation
this
could
i'm not saying it is but i think it
could be
when children are young
they are taught over and over and over
and over again through cartoons this
principle that we should get rid of the
rules that there are no more rules
it makes one wonder
given
time
if you take it to its end conclusion
where do you wind up
i mean it's this is their movie poster
no more rules no more rules at all and
everything goes out the window there has
to be rules that's why that's why i
talked about in the beginning you can't
make a statement saying we're
celebrating 50 years of being able to
love whomever we want doesn't matter age
nothing
gender nothing there's there's a line
there god has a line
there has to be a line it is not fair
for an adult to take advantage of a
child that's not okay
and so
this is kind of one of those things
where you can't say no more rules there
are rules in human sexuality you break
those rules it's a bad road
and this is a sad sad movie and this is
what the second or third one because
fifty shades of grey
okay
so we're getting to that we're getting
um twilight was on there
i always thought whoever read this book
could read the bible because that book
was lying yeah
this whole series is so depressing
okay so i just want to point something
out not not to get too lengthy on this
but she's holding an apple trying to
give it to the man yes this is not my
poster this is their poster but just why
i said i was an apple i don't even know
what the fruit was it i would not risk
my life for an apple apple gets a bad
breath
we don't even have any more okay but i
want you to notice something
he's dreadful
i think okay so this is a whole series
right
terrible series they're not in any sort
of functionable relationships these are
terrible relationships do you notice a
trend that i'm that i'm that i'm going
through here yes these are the highest
grossing romance
movies of all time
i don't know about this one that's with
lady gaga i'm sure you've heard this
song um
yeah in the shadows or whatever yeah
yeah
in the shallow or shallow yeah that's a
very popular song okay so i don't know
anything about that one this one i
really don't know that much about it
these are the new ones yeah ryan gosling
these are new you know dirty singing and
stuff like that
so i want to mention something did you
guys see pearl harbor i did
yeah this girl is in love with this guy
she falls in love with this guy now she
has to choose between these guys well
this guy was missing in action she
thought he was dead
still is still problematic i know it's
still horrible and tragic so this is the
original bachelorette
okay yes
actually had a different ending for jeff
how about this one i've seen that one
okay
romance
prostitute rich guy they fall in love
yeah okay ghost i don't know that one oh
yeah yes
very interesting very interesting that
that um it really centered on the state
of the dead and at the top of the poster
notice that it says believe i'll just
leave it on that cinderella this was
another one
um that was on the list mermaid i
haven't heard of this one
no some some asian one
here's 50 shades of grey getting down to
number nine okay
you know um something that's really
interesting that i heard about her um
this is um oh i don't even remember the
lady's name
oh her her mom her mom is melanie
griffin griffin
yeah and um her real life yeah so i saw
an interview where she talked about
taking this part and her mom heavily
encouraged her not to take this part she
took it anyway do you know she went home
from the set crying every single day you
could see in interviews
literally just like this was the worst
that it was
disturbing yeah it's like it's like
taking
sexuality which should be the epitome of
of pleasure and love towards somebody
else and then adding like sadistic abuse
to it and it's just a bad combination
altogether forrest gump was on the list
jenny
okay i didn't know those uh here's
twilight popping up i want you to notice
a trend here woman two guys okay i want
you to notice oh
wait that wasn't that wasn't the one
that she was first with right
hmm oh yeah i remember this well that
was like a werewolf and one was a
vampire
that's a tough choice yeah i know
they're both like beasts
but but this is this is once again
taking the idea of lust on a spectrum of
love is the opposite of love lust is i
want to take something from you love is
i want to give something to you so this
whole series is is really a twisting of
what it's called it's like what the
devil does he he he entices us into sin
and he said and he claims i'm going to
make you free you can have freedom doing
this but what he's really doing is
enslaving you this is the same type of
operation it's not love it's lust and
it's on the other side of the spectrum
this entire story but these were all the
tops of the story
like i've seen this one this was
surprising to me this was surprising to
me do you know that this story of
aladdin
made a billion dollars do you know why
that's significant oh serious wow wow
how much of the cartoon make a billion
dollars i i have no idea but this one
this one story wasn't released that long
ago this is 2019.
and in this one jasmine here says you
know oh i don't want to follow the rules
anymore and he there's some law that she
has to marry somebody and he's like
basically like hey i can make this law
go away i can just snap my fingers and
it'll just go away that is not a picture
of love love is built on rules and laws
and when you throw out the rules
there is literally
no end what the devil can can can can
cause harm in this right beauty and the
beast
number two wow
do you think is number one
number one
the notebook right or the titanic i
don't is this movies from the well no
because the first one was like 90s
number one
titanic and if you watch this one do you
remember it was kind of messed up oh
yeah
it's like a ladder in an engagement with
somebody else and falls in love with
another guy and the the guy the fiancee
is always some terrible
guy but he has lots of money right so
yeah yeah incline so they justify the
cheating yeah so
once again out of this list of the top
20 highest grossing films do you see any
clear picture of what a real marriage
should look like what real love should
look like well you hardly see marriage
at all it's really just there's a lot of
twisted consequences yeah they never get
married they just have sex and then it's
like a
you never even really hear them say
boyfriend or girlfriend you're just once
you sleep together that births love and
then you just are together yep i can
remember being in high school i think it
was in high school when this movie came
out and i i mean i went to the theater i
saw it there was this crazy sex scene in
there i mean i was
not married or anything yet you know
what i mean he was like really
interested in that
i watched it three times
taking out the sexual part of it that's
interesting like
none of these i'm not sure most of them
are not between like a married couple
and then she like steps out so do these
rules that you're talking about do they
apply since it wasn't a marriage like
just because you're engaged to someone
or you're dating someone are you locked
in can you not go
and
see what else is out there i think
devil's advocate i think in the majority
of these movies they had sex
oh wait we're taking that out i'm just
saying
[Music]
pretty much the movies don't exist then
if you take that part there's one more
story
yes though because there is no
commitment
okay so
you i mean if if we believe as
christians that well you said take out
the sex part but let's say that's only
for marriage but then if you're in a
relationship or in a relationship with
someone and um
like you're you have no you have no
commitment or there is no solid
foundation for relationships you just
you can do whatever you want because
they don't really belong to you
you know you just it's like you have all
the benefits of the relationship but you
never made that commitment so you can
just leave
yeah
i'm surprised the notebook is not on
this list and dirty dancing like i
thought the notebook was like a super
depressing movie did anybody else have
that i mean i almost got stoned for
saying such a thing but and here's why
for one and it was one of the movies
where both the guys were actually
good guys um it was a love triangle and
the other
anyway
there were two good guys oh yeah but the
thing that was super depressing and um
this is a spoiler alert if you haven't
seen it you want to
in the end when they both die
it seemed like a symbiotic relationship
like there was nothing deeper than the
romance they were living for each other
and it was such a hollow ending like
without god you your whole existence is
wrapped up in this person when they're
gone you're just over and it just seemed
like this depressing
what was the point of your life except
just to be married and it just that's
what it ended on and people were like
what's the matter that's the best move
i'm like i was in depression
you bring up a really great point and i
want to bring up a couple of verses
because i think it speaks to what you
just said right there
hebrews 13 4 says let the marriage be
held in honor among them all let the
marriage be undefiled for god will judge
the sexually immoral and adulterous okay
so we're all in danger of of you know a
a pretty harsh judgment there it says
if we are literally
um living outside of what god is asking
for us to do so i find it very alarming
to me that our pop culture our modern
media is pumping out this idea just
sleep with whoever you want and this
this is a pretty straightforward verse
you know it's it's it's it speaks pretty
clearly right here but from what you
just said right there ecclesiastes 4 12
and though a man might prevail against
one um who is alone
two will withstand him a threefold cord
is not easily broken
i i really want to end this conversation
with i believe that god
foresaw that
sin was going to be at our door that's
why i believe he put man with a woman he
said it's not good for you to be alone
why would it not be good for you to be
in in a perfect environment
why would that not be good he created a
perfect environment he said it's not
good for you to be alone
and um you know uh when when adam and
eve and this is maybe debatable
when eve walked away from adam in the
garden is typically how we we read that
um
that the devil was able to communicate
with her but if the two would have been
there maybe it would have been a
different story
and so i i honestly believe that that us
together in a marriage situation is a
stronger
um chord against the devil's attacks but
if we add that third string
that third chord
then we will be
not easily broken
i don't want to regress
but
is that not the notebook she
she made an interesting point and i just
want to make an observation about how
cultures
are different
in in america we're we're really raised
with this idea and i'm not saying it's
necessarily wrong
that you know if it's not the right one
you shouldn't go through it through with
it you know it's not final i mean do
what makes you happy
really
and you know break that thing off
and i do believe that people should not
get into bad relationships
in other cultures though i'm thinking
specifically the jewish culture
once
once like those people were essentially
engaged or or promised to each other or
this is this is the one you're going to
marry is it different story it's it's
not the same culturally that was like at
that point you were
essentially considered married
but you couldn't live together there was
no like
just deciding
uh you know this isn't a good idea we
don't want to do this that was like at
that point if you walk away you're
breaking that contract you're you're now
breaking covenant that's why when mary
came up pregnant it hurt joseph it was
gonna be a big deal
so in the in this country though we have
a little we have more flexible ideas
about that because it's just cultures
change we're different you know and as
society progresses whichever direction
it's going that's that's kind of what
we've adopted
um again i'm not advocating for
you know
stay in a bad relationship
but
we are looking at it through a different
lens whereas in here some of the a lot
of those movies it's like yeah that you
know
don't go through with it it was the
wrong idea you know it's more easily
disposable
but other cultures
and times wouldn't necessarily look at
it that way if you were promised to
somebody that was like it was a done
deal and and breaking that off was a
much a much
uh much bigger deal
yeah
well guys it's been awesome great
conversation thank you for sharing your
input hopefully
we all were edified by today's
conversation thank you guys for tuning
in and watching today
um i hope that you hear some of these
statistics that um you know
the holiday season is a great time for
us to get together in families and and
spend time together but you know a lot
of people feel strained during that time
and i believe that the devil is out to
attack our marriages i can't tell you
how many people i have around me that
are constantly
talking about their marriage problems or
that there is something that is just
attacking or their marriages are falling
apart
so i just want to make a special appeal
to you guys
um you know
we are living in the last days and the
devil wants to divide and conquer us and
he wants to take us out and you know
if you are in a marriage or a covenant
relationship i just want to
pray that you will
listen to some of the advice the things
that have come out in this conversation
spend time with your spouse make god
your your central focus in your
relationship your third string your
third chord that you will not be easily
broken by the devil and
definitely
pray for your marriage pray with your
spouse all the time i believe it makes
an absolute difference in your marriage
i know when i really started taking that
seriously and actually praying with my
spouse it really did make a massive
difference even just in our relationship
so i want to encourage all of you guys
as we come into the new year um we hope
and pray that you will make god a big
part of your life and um we thank you
for watching led we thank you for
supporting us it's been an awesome year
you guys have have just gone above and
beyond if you want to leave a comment
for us we read all those comments if you
have a question we take all those
questions seriously and we will engage
with you so
we thank you guys for watching we hope
you had a wonderful 2021 and we hope
that you even have a better 2022
and we know we're getting that much
closer to jesus coming back so thank you
for watching have a great year we'll see
you guys next year
you